summer is the perfect time to get your
carpets clean there's so many benefits
to carpet cleaning this time of year you
get improved allergy control being
proactive with the pet issues and also
getting rid of the odors and plus while
the weather heats up you prepare your
home for summertime and here to tell us
all about how Zerorez can do that for
you is our good friend Ben McKee with
some helpful tips to return your home
back to clean welcome back you guys Doug
it's so good to have you here definitely
it's good to see your Mercedes well
let's talk about this uh summer is when
I get the most Traction in and out of my
house and it creates some messes zero
res can come in and take care of that
with just water explained absolutely so
like you said it's a busy time of year
and you don't want to call up some
carpet cleaner and get some who knows
what chemicals put into your carpet
that's going to leave your carpets
crunchy and stinky calls you whereas we
can get your carpets clean with our
patented technology it's alkaline water
it's safe and we're about to show you
how effective it actually is yeah I
can't wait to see how works but tell us
more more so than carpet cleaning you
don't just do that one thing I've been
talking to you guys about is having you
out and doing my air ducts I know we do
air ducts we clean commercial properties
we clean upholstery tile and grout is
one of my favorite things to clean
believe it or not but basically if you
have a surface in your home or business
we've got you covered we can get it
cleaned up you really need to look into
doing that the allergies all of that can
get really bad Doug give us an example
here of how this works and again you
said this is just water alkaline water
how can this clean so well being that
it's just water well our water is
treated to act very similar to soap okay
um so it's able to suspend the dirt and
the grease that gets trapped in our
carpets or in your tile and we
immediately suck it up with basically a
300 horsepower vacuum and all that's
left in your carpet is uh it's going to
be a little damp but there's no chemical
residue left behind
and that's why we call it zero res it
stands for zero residue it really is
incred
ible dries super fast and the reason is
you don't have to like we don't have to
keep going over and over and over um on
the cleaning process so we're able to
use less water anyways plus we have the
best equipment out there and you just
it's a home run combination you also
have the best staff out there I know you
guys are very humble but you've received
thousands of five star reviews it's that
last time I checked I think it's like 7
500 Google reviews with a 4.9 star
average and not the brag but it just
shows when you call us up you're going
to get top-notch service you really are
I can vouch for that uh thank you guys
so much and also businesses if you are
looking to clean that Chrome
Zerorez they are the ones for the job
thank you again to Zerorez for
sponsoring this segment you want to
check out their special offer carpets
clean for as low as 35 dollars per room
plus you can receive free tile cleaning
a hundred square feet call them today
702-840-333 or go online to
zerorezlasvegas.com minimum supply Las
Vegas now we'll be right back